[Music]
knock-knock e other singles crash Jack
and Rebecca and the fate of their
marriage were at the center of Tuesday's
emotional season finale of this is us
not I'm not really wanna be set on it
please do not set me up let me set you
up from the very beginning of their
relationship hi hi
to what we learn might be the beginning
of the bitter end of our favorite TV
couple whoa sorry what the hell is that
it's an ear kiss between Rebecca and her
ex bent that caused a drunk jack to do
this ending Rebecca's tour and causing
the couple's realist by ever you look
the things I've had to do I'm happy and
I follow I devoted my life to you so
that I'm gonna take it out my face oh
dear you ridiculous hmm the next morning
Rebecca asks Jack to move out but not
without one last ditch effort from him
you're not just my great love story
Rebecca
[Music]
you mind big break ET caught up with
stars Milo Ventimiglia and Mandy Moore
just after the finale to find out are
they separated I think they needed a
break I think things got heated as
Rebecca said things were said that can't
be taken back in the light of day and
yeah it just means that maybe they're
gonna have to shift and reset I think I
think it leaves people hopeful there's a
lot of promise and and I'm excited and
in the dark just as much as the next
person as to like what happens from here
you